we will colonize mars someday what do
you think answer in the comments below
and suggest a prompt on our kickstarter
you're in vans so thank you
thank you
if you had to rank yourself against
others based on a specific trait
what would it say about how you see them
and how they see you
we asked six high school students to
rank each other based on what they
assumed each other's gpas are then we
rearrange them by their actual gpa this
is a ranking
i guess i guess i'm going first
um i used to be kind of obsessed with
like homework and like doing well and
all that stuff but after quarantine i
realized that i was like missing out on
like the actual high school experience
so this year i'm involved in a lot i'm
the president of the black student union
i'm also the president of our school's
anti-racism and equity task force a
senior class of 22 ambassador
and i'm also on the dance team
yeah i was not in clubs
but i was on track i was managing my
business which i'm currently still
managing with my
i don't know i've never been a part of
any of that that sounds really good
so my freshman year i was president of
my show choir and then sophomore year i
was dance captain of my show choir and
then now i'm doing social media director
for my dance team which i've been on for
30 years i'm also in national honor
society at my school
i was on track and i did swim and then
i'm also a musician if i was in band for
all four years i did like track cross
country i'm also in a few clubs there's
period poverty earth club is another one
and then i do like a lot of community
service i was really worried about some
people because i think sometimes gpa can
be deceptive because i know a lot of
people who are very careless about
school and just go with the flow and
then proceed to have like four point
sixes i feel like grades are not really
a measure of intelligence or worth it's
more so like how good you are at like
the school system in the us like the gpa
system and all that for me personally i
don't feel like it defines who you are
yeah you can agree i've never cared
about school in a way and my parents
always would say like do what makes you
happy and they would never pressure me
yeah and in my family my pressure is
mainly on trying to be top ranks and to
be the first one to go to college um
yeah growing up my brothers didn't do
the greatest and so my parents kind of
shifted onto me yeah i would agree i
don't have that much pressure on me
though it's more just kind of like i
wanted to do good i guess um what
classes you guys take like any ap
classes any honors classes
[Music]
i was like what how do they even have
the energy like i don't even have energy
for normal classes like
yeah i'm gonna go there
she's taking like five ap so i feel like
she should like stay well you're taking
care
when they were placing me in the front i
was just like maybe it's like the
stereotype also like asians tend to have
the stereotype of having really high
gpas he also took a lot of aps too
yeah you might be up too i feel like you
should be like first honestly
do ap classes mean everything though
well for gpa
an extra point or what if you don't have
ap classes but you have a really good
like um like if you take regular because
you can't get over four so that's just
like what i'm thinking i should still
switch with you though i just have a gut
feeling i have a feeling that you're
like yeah
yeah i feel like you should i feel like
i want to say you're first i'm going to
take you one second
okay i think that you have go are you
sure yes i have more faith in you than i
do myself
well i sort of had like a first
impression that i was probably one of
the lower ones so it was more of
replacing them above me than
placing them below me yeah because i
feel like you three are definitely like
yeah you guys are right because nhs a
bunch of ap classes
i was doing good during quarantine but
when we came back it was such a big
shift because we were online for so long
yeah i think uh online lectures i just
can't focus like i'd literally just like
probably play video games in the
background my teachers see this but
i found the opposite like i focus so
much better at home i was a horrible
student during cove
my teachers would like email me like
please just do this assignment
the quarantine happened and then i
started my business and i just like my
grades dropped my friends were telling
me like so you're not smart like what's
wrong i'm like no i am it's just i'm not
a school person like i had more time to
work on my business and it just like
changed my perspective all the way like
is if if this is gonna be my life like i
love it like i'm gonna just keep going
with my business should we do like a
like vote maybe like each person and
then like like a raise of hands who
thinks she's one yeah yeah
okay i think i think so
i was like maybe okay do we think she's
second yeah she's second yeah maybe
i think you are four yeah are you
thinking about that yeah
okay
then two
you're in vans so
that doesn't make sense but like band
kids probably banker director
because you have to have some reading
comprehension to be able to read notes
yeah
as a former band kid that's a good point
okay but i feel like you might surprise
us i'm gonna surprise this
yeah did you take any honors i took a
couple i kind of feel like you should go
like up i think we should switch yeah i
don't think we should say i think you
should switch with my ear
no problem assistant
[Laughter]
all right
first we have
june
and daniella
tied
with a 2.0
next up we have jasmine with the 3.8
then we have
david with a 4.04
joe
with a 4.2
oh
oh thank you
what kind of information do you think
made it possible for you guys to get the
lineup there's like ap classes yes
once i heard ap i said i don't want that
guys
you can kind of tell like how people
approach school by how they talk about
it yeah like if they're just kind of
like oh yeah whatever do you know if
you're going to be val victorian because
that's like the gpa valve victoria's
guys i guess my school is really
competitive yeah no it's definitely not
me there's people who have like higher
gpas than me at my school like fives
that's crazy
middle school i like failed sixth grade
the people were just like flunking too
and so i was just kind of like following
the crowd i still fall on the ground but
i guess like the crowd just look better
and they're doing better in school so
it's helped me more than anything like
starting like in middle school i started
like struggling with like chronic
illness and stuff and so i guess that's
when i also realized that like if people
are like going through something like at
home or like just in life in general
then their grades might not reflect like
how much they're actually good at school
and sometimes like even the college
system like they'll accept people with
lower gpas because they see more people
yeah that's why i was saying like i feel
like it's like more about like how
well-rounded you are that's how it
sounds like you would probably
get into like such a good college
because we have a business i was like
yeah but we got it right
[Music]
you